nous arrivons maintenant au cloud clou
du spectacle est au coût de cette
journée puisque
non
c'est l'histoire
sans deux de ses chevaux d un petit peu
sur le
bon il n'était pas toujours d'accord et
pendant l'été ils se sont réconciliés et
enfin
et enfin camille combal a dit oui oui à
série à la personne et bien ces
répondants quelque chose
mais qui
m
souvent être célébrée par jean luc
lemoine monseigneur le moins bien nommé
qui va donc célébrer cette nasse
on se verse est à vous
mes amis si nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui c'est pour célébrer l'union
de deux êtres exceptionnels
tout d'abord un être charismatique un
leader naturel
un exemple pour toute une génération
cyril hanouna lorsque camille il m'a dit
qu'il voulait épouser cyril je suis dit
tiens il est encore bourré et finalement
non il a juste des goût étrange quand
acier quand je le vois comme ça dans sa
belle petite robe je me dis qu'il a
grandi trop vite qu'amicale combal
acceptez vous de prendre pour épouse
cyril valery issac ici présentes et
promettez-vous de la chérir jusqu'à la
fin de vos jours
évidemment je le veux non c'est oui je
le veux
évidemment ce n'est pas le cas oui je le
veux
cyril valery lissac
acceptez-vous de prendre pour époux
camille karl combal et de le chérir
jusqu'à la fin de vos jours sur la [ __ ]
kenji que je veux
sa paroisse
c'est faible
et vous
les beautés on va se retrouver dans la
mort avec le nouveau 4 pouces pas mon
poste
nouvel an avec tous les chroniqueurs de
touche pas à mon poste c'est dans trois
minutes sur les médias le nouveau
plateau on vous ai mises avait voté à
tout de suite perçu d'hôtel
e